je ne suis pas plus amoureux de la vie
après le coc vide je suis très heureux
en tout cas de vous revoir et de revoir
mes enfants ma femme et les gens que
j'aime
mais je continue j'étais pressé de
travailler de reprendre le travail parce
que le travail
pour moi c'est important mon esprit a
besoin de deux avaient besoin de se
remettre au travail
vous savez je collabore et je travaille
avec avec le mari de legé radine que
voilà je m'éclate depuis cinq ans un sur
rmc et ma convalescence ne passera aussi
que par le travail
voilà donc c'est important pour moi oui
la famille bien sûr mais tu sais quand
tu acceptes ton destin avec ta décidé
d'accepter la mort parce que c'était
doux c'était quelque chose de doux je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas souffert au
suffoquer je me suis juste laisser aller
un peu comme comme une anesthésie et
c'était doux c'était beau voilà il vous
vous êtes dit je suis en train de mourir
vous pensez vraiment vous étiez en train
de mourir ouais parce que à ce moment il
ya un moment où je vois un voile blanc
je vois plus personne vous savez quand
vous rentrez en réa ça il ya douze
personnes autour de vous vous êtes piqué
aux artères mon cas des douleurs de
partout vous êtes branché vous avez des
débris partout donc c'est c'est une
ambiance particulière
daria c'est soit vous en sortez soit
vous y rester voilà moi de ce que j'ai
vu je n'ai pas vu de personnes âgées
j'ai vu des jeunes de mon âge au service
des maladies infectieuses
j'ai vu des cas qui était qui était
terrible donc les je peux comprendre que
les gens ont besoin de sortir
que ce soit les étudiants qui souffre
énormément et on pourra jamais mettre un
degré sur la souffrance parce que ceux
qui se disent entre guillemets qui
pensent qu'il ya un ordre là haut qui
décide effectivement que le coc vide et
une partie de poker
je peux vous assurer que ce que j'ai eu
c'est tout sauf une grippe
voilà les gens souffrent encore et le
pire et pardonne moi de continuer
là-dessus
le pire c'est pas le fait d'être en rien
c'est la convalescence posco vide
quand ton corps réagit très mal aux aux
inflammations du coc vide j'ai enchaîné
les merdes j'ai eu des douleurs je
t'assure que je ne souhaite pas mon pire
ennemi
j'ai enchaîné une embolie pulmonaire ce
que j'ai enchaîné une
je me souviens plus du nom voilà un
épanchement pleural donc de l'eau dans
les poumons avec où j'ai un traitement
anticoagulant qui va qui va traîner
pendant de très longs mois et je peux
t'assurer que on souffre terriblement
n'arrive pas à tarif lui a marché il
faut cure après la marche et à respirer
donc voilà donc il faut beaucoup d'amour
des gens autour de vous la famille c'est
important est de toute façon ceux qui
pensent que ce qu vide entre guillemets
est une plaisanterie le joris le frappe
mais je leur souhaite pas de tout coeur
ils pourront comprendre mais je vais aux
témoignages ce soit avant de dire je
repense à toutes les personnes ici à ils
nous ont dit oui il faut ça va faut
arrêter fois régalé violent chez de
vivre c'est les vieux et ça c'est une
idée moyens je pense qu'on leur sortie
rachat pu avoir une personne qui dira ça
sur ce plateau
ouais parce que vraiment vous nous dire
là je suis je pensais pas vraiment été
aussi en touche et maintenant c'est une
souffrance faut pas croire et j'en
souffre encore aujourd'hui parce qu'il
faut se lever les foules à
l'entraînement il faut il faut prendre
ton traitement cirque sais pas je me
souviens j'étais au service des maladies
infectieuses je pouvais regarder la télé
et j'avais regardé l'émission il y avait
un jeune qui organisait des soirées un
rayon de 300 personnes tu sais les
listes sont pleins il manque de moyens
je me disais si ces 300 personnes choper
le coc vide et qu'ils arrivaient en rien
ouais et puis arrivé d'abord en bas
avant faut s'enregistrer avant et qui
reste que dolly balesi battez-vous
maintenant c'est une catastrophe ce qui
se passe là-bas et est vraiment faut
qu'il fasse attention c'est des choses
terribles qui se passer de tout coeur
faut qu'il fasse attention tout
simplement on pourra pas dire à
quelqu'un dit croire ou ne pas croire
c'est comme un croyant
il croit en ce qu'il veut tu vois il va
pas le forcer à croire ce que tu crois
moi je parle de ce que j'ai vu ce que
j'ai subi